this boy is not a baby he's four years
old according to the UN there are three
million chronically undernourished
children and pregnant women in Yemen
we've been here for 13 days we have to
pay for medical care ourselves we need
to have an x-ray and more tests done but
we simply can't afford them
[Music]
this boy is dreadfully weak the acute
malnutrition has made his hair fall out
but his family have no means to feed him
properly the war here has all but
destroyed the poverty ridden country
millions are malnourished and the UN is
unable to give aid to all those who
needed constant malnutrition can cause
lasting damage and because medical
provisions here have been reduced to the
bare essentials it's the very weakest
who are most affected children
[Music]
please to them that are affected by
stunting they'll have it for life if the
first if their brain is damaged when
they're under two or three years they
live on cover and that's I think one of
the biggest tragedies that we seen in
this situation almost 19 million people
desperately need aid in Yemen over 70%
of the population and many of them
received nothing like the people in this
camp there are no doctors in this
provisional camp for displaced people a
young volunteer distributes vitamin
tablets talks to people about hygiene
and checks children to see if they're
developing normally this girl is
severely malnourished she needs to be
treated
but that's only possible in hospitals
the family can't afford to stay in
hospital of course in Yemen rebels
supported by Iran are fighting against
an overthrown government which is
supported by Saudi Arabia we have no
work
we have no income no money we have
nothing not even water we're at God's
mercy how that abuse
since the war started in March 2015
there have only been losses in Yemen
many of them children